Some emotional
testimony that we went
we witnessed
and watched this morning on Capi
That's coming from survivors of
Q mass shooting in Colorado Spri
They spoke to lawmakers in Washi
about their experiences
and also
the rise of anti LGBTQ
rhetoric and violence.
Melanie is known as live on Capi
She's been watching this all mor
For us.
Melanie,
what's been happening in this he
Yeah, there's been an emotional
And the last one
I should point out from the Hous
Oversight Committee before
Republicans take over.
Chairwoman Carolyn
Maloney has been a longtime
advocate for LGBTQ rights.
And so this is an issue near
and dear to her heart.
The goal of the hearing was to e
how anti LGBTQ policies
have fueled a rise
in violence against the communit
as well as the rise in extremist
we have seen online.
We heard from experts
who testified to that,
who talked about ways
to reduce hate crimes.
With Republicans pushing back on
that their policies
were in any way responsible
for some of these horrific shoot
and instead
blaming the overall rise in crim
But aside from the policy debate
we heard about the real life imp
We heard from some of the surviv
from that club Q shooting
where a gunman walked into a clu
that was a safe
haven for the gay community
and opened fire,
killing five people
and injuring many others.
One of those survivors, Michael
a bartender, talked
about his horrific experience th
And also advocated for a ban
on assault weapons. Take a liste
I saw my friend lying on the flo
bleeding out,
knowing there was little to no c
of surviving that bullet wound.
I had to tell him goodbye
while I continue to fear for my
as leaders of our country.
It is your obligation to represe
all of us,
not just the ones
you happen to agree with.
Hate speech turns into hate acti
And actions based on hate
almost took my life from me.
At 25 years old,
now, we should also point out
it is the ten year anniversary
today of the shooting
massacre at Sandy Hook Elementar
Congress has only taken
incremental steps, though,
to reduce gun violence
and to protect the LGBTQ communi
and hate.
It's only going to be harder
in a divided Congress next year.
That's a good point and a harsh
That's right. Melanie, thank you
Appreciate it.
Joining me now is James Long.
He survived the club to attack
and he also is
another one
who just testified in that House
And also with us is Sara Kate El
She's the CEO and president of G
James, let me start with you.
What what was it like for
you sitting
and speaking to lawmakers today?
What was your message to them?
My message was regarding,
first of all, addressing hate rh
We need to as Americans, as poli
as media outlets,
we need to stop the hate rhetori
We need
to be more cognizant of how we s
And my certainly
my other message was to the comm
we need to embrace love.
We need to not be afraid.
We need to be loud and proud.
James, how does this sit with yo
Well, as Melanie was laying out,
if you want to call it a policy
dispute, though, it is a very re
It is could not be more real lif
than what you lived through.
When you have some
Republican members
on that committee
blaming
the violence and attacks on the
LGBTQ plus community, on the ove
in crime and violent crime
we've seen across the country.
I think that erases our identity
and it erases
just how targeted and marginaliz
how dehumanized we have become.
Just blaming an overall rise
in violence is not the answer.
That is
that's not going to solve anythi
I was disappointed, to say the l
You were disappointed,
extremely disappointed.
Just hearing those words and bei
victim of
a mass shooting,
taking a bullet in the arm
and then having to committee mem
walk out during our testaments,
our testimonials there.
That was just disappointing
you.
As you mentioned, you were shot.
You're recovering from your woun
Your boyfriend was shot.
Your sister was shot multiple ti
And you all are you all are reco
still for for you.
James, is it
the physical wounds
or the mental trauma
that is the greater challenge
to work through
after what you've lived through
and now you're still processing?
I I think it might be a little b
of both.
So, I mean, obviously,
the wounds here, I'm
going to
have to go through physical ther
but the mental trauma for me
has kind of fueled a fire of fir
that we need to do better.
We need to,
you know, address this hate rhet
We need to be advocates and
we need change.
Sarah, can you talk to
me about what you see
as the impact of rhetoric
in fueling
hateful violence
against the LGBTQ community?
I mean, this is a type of this t
of hate
is not new to the LGBTQ communit
But do you see it as different n
I see it as much more amplified
than it's ever been before.
And I think just to put this on,
the rise of crime
takes away
all of the attacks
that have been coming
at the LGBTQ community.
Over 300 anti-LGBTQ bills propos
this past year.
150 attacks on drag
events and LGBTQ events this pas
And when you see what's happenin
with the political rhetoric
that is then going on
social media platforms
completely unchecked,
it's turned into action
that boils over into our communi
and ends up at the front door of
like Club Q.
So it's really
it does a complete disservice
to blame this or point
this just on a rise in crime.
This is targeted
against our entire community.
We are being used as political f
for right
wing media and right wing
politician and extremists.
And it's having
I mean, the Homeland Security
two weeks ago put us on a target
to look out for ourselves becaus
we are being targeted
James
you were you were thrust into th
I mean, you've you now
you're talking about
you must become an advocate
and your experience is fueling t
But what is it like for you
I mean, you said you're disappoi
in what you heard from
some of the members on the panel
Do you do you regret
testifying before them because o
Not at all.
I am so glad that I could share
I am so glad for Chairwoman Malo
for allowing me to do so.
That was
that was an incredible experienc
And I think
I'm glad that we can all share o
I'm glad that,
you know, I'm
not going to forget this ever.
And I want other people to know
what it's like
I want other people
to understand our struggles
at the very same time. James.
There is a moment
also a bright spot for
for you and the community as wel
I mean, you were at the White Ho
for the
signing of the Respect for Marri
just yesterday.
And I heard in an interview
with CNN
that you said that
that what that has shown to you
is that love wins.
And it's kind of this juxtaposit
mashed into one of what you're
talking about today.
And also then what you saw yeste
This law doesn't
do everything,
but what does this law mean for
This law means
that this
is one step closer to equal righ
This is one step closer for me
being able to marry the person I
and not have to be targeted
by politicians.
And it's going to, I think,
help with that hate rhetoric.
I think it's going to
to start to taper off that hate
That's where we're going with th